there's a friend of mine who's got a  great saying about creating a company um  which is  creating trying to build a company and  have it succeed is like eating glass and  staring into the abyss  so i mean what tends to happen is it's  sort of quite exciting for the first  several months of starting a company and  then then reality sets in things don't  go as well as planned customers aren't  signing up the technology or the product  isn't working as well as you thought  and  and then that can sometimes be  compounded by a recession  um and  it can be  very very painful for several years um  so i think  um  frankly starting a company  i would advise people to have a high  pain tolerance